hey there folks welcome back to the
YouTube live stage here at PAX Prime
2015 I'm Chris waters from gamespot.com
here to talk about The Witcher 3 with
Jacob and Travis from CD Projekt RED now
one of the greatest things about pax is
that developers from all over the world
come travel to come talk about their
games get to get on panels and you guys
are gonna be talking about The Witcher 3
2 on Sunday
yeah about adapting a game from a novel
or a series of novels I guess is more
accurate right so let's talk about that
today I guess first before we get into
it Jacob
Travis once you guys tell us a little
bit about what you do at CD Projekt RED
ok so I'm a senior writer at CD Projekt
RED so basically I write the dialogue
and come up with ideas for quests for
The Witcher alright and I'm a translator
so yeah kuba or that's what we call him
over there that's sort of Jacob
accomplished kuba writes in Polish and
then we've got a team of two Polish
English translators and we immediately
put that right into English and from
there it hits the rest of the world and
it's translated all the other language
without though you guys certainly have
your hands full because there is just a
ton of story a ton of dialogue and in
The Witcher 3 and it's also good it's
one of the things that makes that game
so wonderful and so immersive let's talk
like just sort of broad level like you
know you guys had had some momentum from
previous games but then there's also
these books sub cough skis which are
books that are so so popular in Poland
especially like how do you sort of chart
a course like where do you even get
started with charting a course for The
Witcher 3 amongst all that lore that
exists and amongst the story you've
already told in The Witcher and The
Witcher 2 well so we knew from the
beginning that this will be a huge
challenge because we'll have to make a
game which is accessible to people who
haven't read the books and haven't
played a previous games and at the same
time we couldn't afford to disappoint
our fans who know all the books by heart
and they know the games so it was a very
difficult balancing act to get it right
but I think in the end it kind of worked
out so so we were happy about it did you
guys have like a required reading lists
that everyone on the team had it like
gout before starting the projects we
definitely we try to encourage everyone
to read the books which is kind of a
challenge because our team has become
quite international so we have a lot of
people who aren't Polish and the last
couple books aren't available in an
official English translation so you know
we had to kind of point them toward some
of the fan translations or give them
summaries ourselves so they could get
caught up on those translations are
underway right yeah do you guys also has
it seems like the the success of The
Witcher the games has fed back into like
real interest in the books has it been
as I've been a cool sort of side effect
of what you guys have been doing kits of
kind of a circle where the success of
the games encourages people to pick up
the book and the other way around where
people first started with the book and
then they hear about a game and they
pick it up so yeah I think I think the
books have becoming are becoming more
popular in the US which is great because
they're a fantastic read they're so fun
and there's so many like there's so much
character in those books that really
comes through in the game and sort of
makes those books uniquely suited
certainly in the last wish it's like
there's a bunch of just vignettes of
just like yep this kind of a standalone
story of the time the Garrett was riding
through the forest and heard this
strange sound and like went off and
investigated it they became this whole
thing and like that's an experience you
have in the game which makes every one
of those question marks so fiendishly
tempting mm-hmm I'm curious to know when
you guys think of you know you start
thinking of a story that you want to
tell in the game do you think about okay
like how is this going to what what
quest beats what actions do I want
Geralt to do or do you just think like I
want this to be a story first and then
I'll build in the quest structure after
it or like soon which comes first is it
chicken or egg it depends so sometimes
the impulse comes from the story team so
we have an idea that we really want to
introduce to the game and then we
discuss with the guys on a gameplay side
how we can do it best and sometimes they
come up with us and they tell us that
they just came up with a new mechanic
that they want to have a story around it
and actually the last which is a great
example because we introduced the
swimming and diving mechanic quite late
in the development because we initially
didn't intend garel to be able to died
and then when this was done we were told
that it will be great if we could
incorporate that into the story
and actually it's a big part of the last
wish quest and I think it came together
really really well yeah man although the
first time you get under the water and
you see those drowners coming at you
it's not only unnerving yeah it is I
have a question for you
Travis sort of in terms of translation
right because I and I guess you to Jacob
there's so much you know translating a
line of dialogue is one thing but then
you guys go into all of the monster
names and then you talk about all of the
alchemical substances and the rune
stones like the how do you like decide
what kind of words you're even going to
use and what for it for this stuff I
mean some of them exists in in lore and
stuff like that but you just make some
of them up - yes absolutely like we just
it doesn't differs depending on h1
sometimes we keep it quite close to the
polish word but we try to make sure
it'll actually be pronounceable in each
target language so like for example one
of the most iconic monsters in The
Witcher 3 in Polish is the Lesha and so
we just changed that to lechon in
English sort of a slightly more
pronounceable version but other ones
like for example in the barren quest you
have this I think there's a legend fight
going on over here next to here on the
PAC's front floor either that or there's
a revolution in the maze so you saying
about the barren yeah the barren quest
you've got this this little monster that
is actually made from a dead fetus a
sort of miscarried fetus and the word in
Polish there is plural notes which sort
of conveys a lot of that specific
information about what kind of monster
that is so that's in those cases we
tried to make something up and we called
it a bottling you know something that
was botched and it's making in the combo
yeah wait a reference probably one of
the number one creepiest creatures in
your entire game good work Tavis I yeah
that's it something to conceal like
because you also The Witcher has this
you know it sort of said in a world
that's vaguely fairytale but it's also
dark but it's also funny like there are
there are these humorous twists in the
books and in the games and I remember
the one quest where Daryl gets a little
device that can
talk to his mage friend over a long
distance called the xenovox he makes a
crack about oh it's the weight are these
things just gonna become super popular
and every majors gonna be using them on
every street corner like what is your
approach to humor and trying to get in
those kind of modern tongue-in-cheek
jokes so of course the winter world is
primarily a dark fantasy RPG but it's an
adventure which takes about 100 hours to
complete so we couldn't just keep the
same tone throughout because you'd get
tired quite quickly so I think it's the
change of tone of the change of the feel
of the quest that really allows this
moment to have a you know train to
resonate with you yeah so every once in
a while we want to lighten the mood and
and you know we come up with some jokes
to relieve the tension it was pretty
impressive you guys you know you slide
in a pulp fiction reference and it just
feels totally normal yeah yeah this
doesn't feel washed in or doesn't like
take me out of the experience at all you
know that's something I think we'll talk
a bit more about on Sunday because
that's actually there in SAP Coast as
well like he definitely there's a lot of
humor in there and he does a lot of
pastiche she brings in stuff from
different sort of media different from
the present-day and so we kind of took
some inspiration from him there as well
now when you guys are telling the story
there's most of it is played out through
you know through dialogue or through
conversational scenes and then of course
there's the quest descriptions that you
read but then there's also a few times
in the game where you sort of flash away
to parchment and ink this animation as
Geralt kind of has it like voices his
internal monologue how did the how did
sort of that's kind of seen sort of come
about why did you guys think that was
necessary what what problem did that
solve to like to have that kind of scene
in there do you want to thank us yeah
sure we really like using those to show
the consequences of your actions I mean
whenever possible we try to show those
in the game world itself and through the
dialogues but sometimes there were
things where it just didn't quite fit to
have that end dialogue or a cutscene or
something and so that's another way to
just sort of say yes what you did is
part of this whole living world
and what you did has these sort of
effects and that's how it turnes
sometimes we use it to show the concept
consequence of your actions which go
beyond the game yeah so did you know
that the vm influenced the world in a
significant way but you won't see the
consequence right away is something that
will happen in the future mm-hmm yeah
and those those kind of consequence
trees the I just I'm picturing like the
design documents you guys must have just
go on and on mapping out contingency
after contingency did you ever get to
the point where you wanted to do like
another branch or another path but it
just became too much and you had to say
like oh we need to we need to wrap this
up and move on to the next yeah there is
this moment we of course we wanted to
give flower players as much freedom as
possible but there's a a point in which
you have to say stop because otherwise
you won't be able to wrap things up
again and also doing an open-world game
with so much only art nonlinearities is
even more difficult because you have to
make sure that all these quests work and
they respectively of what decisions you
made and it respectively of the order in
which you made it and sometimes it's
like playing a giant Jenga game where
you just remove something and then the
entire structure collapses so so it was
a lot of juggling too or you remove
something and wait to see yeah yeah is
it gonna hold up yeah all right one of
the things that you know that is so rich
about this game is the amount of like
books that you can read in poems you can
find it's even the songs you hear and
I'm wondering especially with the poems
and the songs there's a certain kind of
structure to those that is not in the
prose you know you could translate a
paragraph in a quest description but
then you translate a paragraph of a song
and it's a much bigger challenge I keep
talking a little about trying to do that
Travis oh yeah yeah those are actually
my favorite things to translate when I
when they throw in a poem or something
I'm like yes this is gonna be fun
because it is such a challenge and well
what we usually try to do is if it's
rhyming and polish it'll rhyme in
English if it has a strict meter and
polish it'll have some kind of meter in
English although never the same meter
because just linguistically that doesn't
work and so actually this my favorite
quest to translate was the UH plays the
thing the one in novigrad with the
Doppler where you
because that was all in rhyming couplets
in Polish and so it's just I don't know
it just taxes your creativity so much to
try to translate that stuff but it ends
up being a ton of fun did you ever go
back to Jake up and you're like dude
these lines are killing me can you just
tweak them a little bit like just give
me something else I recall there was
this one case where I wrote the dialogue
where girl Danny ennifer engaged as sort
of a verbal pun were in and one of the
one of the quests uh-huh and and they
basically use proverbs or sayings to
kind of tease each other and Travis came
in and say are you sure this is gonna
end up in a game because if I spend my
you know eight hours trying to make this
work in English and then it's God I'm
gonna be really angry and you know
reassured that this is definitely going
to be in the game and it is so and then
I think players like this seem quite a
lot yes to hear battle back and forth on
the creative process and if anyone's at
PAX you guys can hear more about the
back and forth of the creative process
on Sunday what time was the panel or
Ferdie p.m. at the Hydra theater
fantastic
Jacob Travis thank you so much for
coming on the stage here and talking
about Witcher 3 folks for more stuff on
The Witcher 3 as the Year continues and
as we approach Game of the Year
discussions later this year go over to
gaming die youtube.com slash GameSpot
give us a star and you'll be up to date
on all GameSpot's witcher 3 content
thanks for joining us here at pax prime
and we'll be live continuing with more
game demos in just a minute